I was listening to your decoration
episode and it really hit me that I
think I think those belongings are what
adding to my foreveralone priority list
and I'm a high anxiety person and I'm
pretty busy I have a two-year-old
toddler who has a lot of stuff I have a
husband who's a mechanic who has a lot
of stuff on the future I have a lot of
stuff empty high anxiety I feel like
everything is on my priority list
everything from getting my dogs he's
clean and being a good owner to you know
certain things and I just wanted to find
out what I do to maybe help my anxiety
and help progress in getting rid of
pontius bang without totally losing my
mind I might kind of like wanting to go
on leave from work so I stay in my house
and forth through every pan just throw
everything away at bro week so I just
wanted to find out if maybe there was a
better way to do that or a better way to
actually prioritize things without
thinking everything is top priority now
right now I was a little bit worried
when she said I'm thinking about taking
a leave of absence from my work so I
could stay at home and she had like this
little pause there mmm and it was just
it was the agoraphobe thing that I was
talking about but then she said I want
to stay home for a week so it sounds
like maybe she has a plan to deal with
some of this excess stuff that's going
on in her life yeah or in her life
but but their lives her family's life
her husband and and her kid and
obviously she's a teacher and so she has
to deal with a certain amount of things
now she talked about many of the
belongings being a priority in her life
and the thing that I want to stress here
is I think belongings are rarely a true
priority I think what she was saying was
all of her possessions so it started
with the decorations right but then she
talked about her husband saw her stuff
her kids stuff
uh-huh like everything that is stressing
her out she feels like they're all her
priorities yes but she has so many
priorities okay that it's it's it's
producing this anxiety in her life
right and so I mean obviously if you go
if you go back to the root of the word
priority and Greg McEwan talks about
this in his book essentialism we didn't
have a plural for the word priority
until the 20th century it literally
means the first thing right you can't
have a hundred the first things right it
just doesn't even work grammatically
right
and so having having a hundred
priorities means I have no priorities at
all I don't have a priority right and I
think ultimately she needs to she said I
have a very busy life and and the thing
I wrote down here Ryan is busy does not
mix with anxiety and I've learned that
in my own life hmm
in fact I was talking about dr. on the
he called me up and he was like hey man
can I bother you I know you're really
busy and I was like how dare you don't
you say that to me
that's the worst four-letter word in the
English language is busy because really
all that means is your life is out of
control and so here's the good news
Fallon I think that you've identified
the fact that hey you know what your
life is really busy it's out of control
right now exactly your life is out of
control and you've identified that
because quite often we don't know we're
out of control
until we're like spinning off of the
road and it's too late we're already
headed into the crash but the news for
you
Fallon is yeah you are headed it toward
a crash and it's gonna happen unless you
course correct now but that's the good
news you have a crash yet the best time
the course correct is before the crash
yeah the anxiety that you're feeling
right now Fallon is is in regards to
you've got to take action towards this
stuff mm-hmm
it is obviously while you're calling and
talking about how it's causing anxiety
so if it's affecting you to the point
where you're calling us it's probably
affecting how your attitude when you're
under kids when you're around your
husband so how did she get out of this
Josh how does she
how does she prioritize her priorities
two things number one is I think you
have to realize that not everything is
equal and that's my biggest problem lay
I will have a task list and it can have
a hundred priorities on it right I got
100 priorities of my task list and I'll
just start going through them and I'll
usually go toward the thing that is
easiest first why because we we tend to
go toward the path of least resistance
the easiest things are usually the least
meaningful things though and so if I
have a hundred things and eighty of them
are easy I'll never get to the twenty
things that are actually meaningful or
productive or something that truly adds
value to my life because I'm so focused
on well I gotta check email gotta gotta
make sure you're all caught up on
Instagram whatever it is like I'm just
so focused on let's get that off the
list get that off the list get that off
the list the thing is you can actually
get a lot of those things off your list
by saying no to them and so that's the
second thing we have to get better at
saying no and and I'm really good at
saying no except here's the problem for
me I have a hard time saying no to the
people closest to me Ryan to Bex and to
you I want because I really care about
you I want to please you I want to be
able to say yes now it's better for me
to say yes to you then it would be some
stranger on the street hey could I spend
three hours of your time talking to you
about blogging I mean I'd love to but I
don't have infinite resources I don't
have the infinite time so I'd love to
say yes to you before someone like that
but sometimes when I'm saying yes to you
or Bex
that means I'm saying no to to myself
and I'll give you an example from from
yesterday Bex likes me to pick her up
from the airport her and Ella were
flying in yesterday and for me to go to
LAX is about a three hour trip there and
back what time were they landing six
o'clock oh my god yeah yeah so could
have turned into a four hour trip right
yeah and I
I often almost always say yes I can
count on one hand with three digits left
how many times I've said noted that
yesterday was well I had to say no to to
them and say hey can you just please get
an uber because I had so I was preparing
for this podcast there's all kinds of
irony and being extra anxious preparing
for anxiety podcast but and so I had a
lot of things to do yesterday to prepare
for today and tonight we're doing some
filming and I was preparing for that
and and I had to call a bunch of people
yesterday there was all kind of stuff
going on so I just had to say no I don't
have time to spend three or four hours
and which is fine but then on the uber
ride home backs texts me and she's like
hey can you go pick me up some
Chipotle's so that we're you know by the
time Ellen I get home we'll have to have
dinner there and I'm like okay yeah I
mean yes because I don't I'm afraid to
say no to you yeah so I said yes and it
totally like increased my anxiety levels
again because I'm like I'm in the middle
of doing this stuff that I perceive to
be important and and meaningful and but
it's also meaningful to provide food for
Ella and backs are coming home but I
should have said no and here's here's
what you can do why don't you you could
do a poor eats you could do you have it
delivered right to the house if you want
there's technology involved so that I
don't have to spend 45 minutes to an
hour going to get you something to eat
yeah right and break that that whole
flow and so instead of just ignoring it
and letting that fester let my anxiety
get higher Beck's and I had a brief
conversation about it and she's like I'm
so sorry you know I didn't think about
it I should have I should have thought
that way I said yeah I should have
thought that way too I should have said
no I said hey can you can you do this
and so next time we know and so it's
really about adjusting accordingly so
getting better at saying no how do you
build that muscle you continue to do it
every single day and you'll fail like I
failed yesterday but you'll learn
something from it and you'll move
forward accordingly what a great example
for Fallon man because relying on her
partner relying on her husband for help
that's huge I mean Fallon you know
here's what I would do if I was you so
everything you've said I totally agree
the thing that I would add is you've got
to get clear on what it is that you want
to get done Fallon so write down
everything that you want to get done on
a list do not prioritize it which is
more important what is it more important
to just write it all down so at least
you know what you need to get done and
then go to your husband and then say hey
honey here are the things that are
really really stressing me out yeah and
I know that I've got a problem and that
this is stressing me out but you're such
an amazing husband that I know that
you're gonna go out of your way
to help me take care of these things and
if you don't actually help me take care
of these these things I know you're at
least going to support me taking care of
these things because you're such a great
husband and oh by the way when you look
at this list what do you what stands out
to you what what is the most important
thing to you does any of this stuff
stress you out as well and kind of
approach it from you know like a team
aspect I think as you're looking at that
as a team you'll look at that list
whenever there's 20 things on there for
me this morning I was going through
through my I don't have a to-do list I
have a today list and then I have a some
day list and like that's how I
prioritize and so I was looking at that
today list and there were four things on
it and I'm like okay is it what if just
in a hypothetical world I deleted half
of these mmm
would the world keeps spinning with my
life be okay if I didn't do any of these
things and the truth was there was one
thing for sure I could just remove
immediately and and my life was still
fine in fact I feel good now because
I've removed that responsibility that
anxiety inducing responsibility then
that allows me to focus on the other two
or three things that are truly important
and so sometimes you don't even have to
say can you help me out with this before
you even get to that you can say I'm
gonna instantly say no to these things
that aren't important I pretended they
were important that I treated them as if
they were just as important as these
other truly important things but they're
not that at all they're they're worth
deleting yeah so Fallon come up with a
plan like I said write down everything
that you need to to accomplish go to
your husband and ask him to help you
come up with a plan but you know here's
the thing Fallon is it sounds like
you've got a lot of a lot of things on
your plate and yes I agree she should
probably maybe take a couple of these
things off the plate if if possible
right but ultimately to get where you
want to be Fallon it's gonna take a lot
of work and as Josh and I always say
simple is not easy yeah simple as simple
is really really difficult in fact easy
is just continuing to ignore these
priorities and to continue letting
things build up and to continue to go
with the flow and easy can be
anxiety-producing for ya absolutely for
me like if I just starts focused on the
easy
to do it means I'm letting I'm putting
on the back burner of the things it
should be the most important to me so
going with easy well maybe in the short
term distract you like the Instagram
thing we were talking about earlier but
but long term it's just going to
increase your anxiety now talking about
a plan she said well what do I take a
week off work and do the things I wanna
do that might that might work for you
but realize that even if you clear your
plate completely there's gonna be new
things that come on to the plate and
that's okay I mean because the opposite
is you have nothing on your plate ever
and that sounds to me like a not a life
well-lived at all yeah I don't honestly
I don't
I am totally unbiased to a balanced plan
whatever plan she comes up with I
support but she's got to come up with a
plan right a plan that that will
actually address the issues as opposed
if taking a week off work would be great
if you just wanted to quit work
altogether so you can stay at home and
constantly reorganize your possessions
that would be a bad plan so a plan that
is actually going to feel meaningful to
you see what else I got here she said I
feel like I will lose my mind I wish she
said it's just something about getting
rid of these things if she feels like
she doesn't get rid of them how can I
develop a plan to get rid of things
without losing my mind is I think what
what she said and for me is like well
you might lose your mind if you don't
come up with a plan to get rid well I
think what she's really saying is is she
doesn't even know where to start with a
plan mm-hmm and maybe that's why she
feels like she's she's losing her mind
is because there's so much she doesn't
even know where to begin
yeah and found it doesn't matter where
you begin it really doesn't just start
somewhere
yeah come up with a plan and start
working the plan otherwise yeah you are
gonna lose your mind for sure well
Fallon I'd love to send you a copy of
our book essential it's an essay
collection 150 essays about intentional
living I think there are two maybe three
chapters you're really fine valuable
there's a chapter on priorities in there
and so we're talking about
prioritizations there's an entire
chapter about priorities with several
essays about how to prioritize and
there's a chapter on success redefining
what success looks like for you because
success can't be well if I accomplish
all of my to-do list and all of a sudden
I'm successful
so make a certain amount of money that
I'm successful that's just another type
of to-do list and so there's a chapter
on success and there's also a chapter on
stuff in there and it looks like fallon
is is struggling to deal with some of
her stuff so we give you some practical
tips to address that stuff Sean if you
could reach out to Fallon and give her
an audiobook version of essential
because if you enjoy the podcast I think
you'll enjoy the the audiobook version
or if she wants the the book book
version of the eBook version were happy
to send those to her as well
you